[Music]
welcome back to the forge in this round
of competition you'll have to forge
signature blades using a piece of 1084
steel your blade also must be made out
of barbed wire good luck blade Smiths
Your timate Design window starts
now I'm making sort of like a camp knife
I like a design that's easy to use and
easy to modify my design is a clip Point
hunter that will pierce slice and
chop my game plan is to do a Anglo-Saxon
style Sachs broke back it has a really
nice Point Your Design period is closed
your 3-hour Forge time
starts now my plan for the knife is to
try to infuse the bwire toward the spine
on the 1084 and not have so much Along
The Cutting Edge cuz I don't know how
hard I can get that Bob
wire I'm going to hammer the bar flat
I'm going to take 6 in strips of the Bob
wire Hammer them flat and then Forge
weld them into the metal if the forge
weld holds it I'm going to do it again
and we'll see what happens how crazy is
this
bobir I love the way he says it bobir
bobir the hardest part about using Bobb
wire is it being small trying to forge
well that to something thicker my plan
is to make two equal bundles of the barb
wire and squeeze them down to as small
as I can get them so I have two pieces
to put on each side I have a forge
welded piece but this blade right now is
giving me some problems I've got a blade
that looks like this and it's way too
sharp of a
curve oh dang Robbie's got a knife over
there look at that he is really moving
along I'm grinding the slag off the
sides of the blade to check my Forge
whes it's a good solid whale I'm
extremely excited I'm going to rock this
thing uh have the blade in the size that
I want so I wed on the
Barre the rhythm of a good airhammer is
hard for a glad Smith to
resist my blade is finally where I can
accept it and I don't want to waste any
more time I want to get this to heat
treat Josh is really being careful with
this whole thermocycling that's good I
pull out my blade on the final cycle and
I'm ready to
quench pull it out initially is looking
good so I go all right let's cool it off
a little bit
more
at this point I think I cool it off too
much because it starts
going the blade just
continues I don't know about you guys
but I'm starting to see some frustration
with Josh there that significant of a
warp is hard to come back from I'm not
sure I'm going to be able to get this
warp out and even though I'm running out
of time I make the decision I'm going to
quench
again come on baby straight hard no
crash the blade is born when it goes
into the Quench and it's straight and
it's
hard it's straight it's hard it's a
boy this time I'm going to haat treat my
blad with a torch the way I do at
home little happy dance and in the
oil 3 2 1 blad Smith shut down your
machines drop your tools the forging
time is
over blade Smith this is the strength
and durability test I'll be taking your
knives and chopping into this Barb Wire
twice Robbie are you ready I'm ready you
better be the knife is too
good
we did get a little bit of edge damage
okay I am surprised though that this
handle didn't give me much more trouble
than it did actually it's it index as
well even though it's
Square Josh you're
[Music]
[Applause]
next
but Josh it looks like your
Edge has no damage so all that time you
took and your heat treating your
thermocycling paid off overall well done
thank you good
job Ray I know you're ready always
ready Ray
I like the way your knife feels thank
you a little bit on the thick side but
it still it's got the kind of edge that
just gets into things so overall well
done Ray thank you sir for the sharpness
test I'll be turning you over to
Doug hi
Doug blad smithz I'm going to take your
weapon and I'm going to see how well it
stabs I'm going to see how well it cuts
on these Kevlar reinforced bags let's
see if your weapons are for real Robbie
you're up first you ready yes
[Music]
sir okay Robbie stabbing was good of
three layers you only cut through two
overall your blade is sharp to stab and
cut yes good job thank you Josh you're
up next you ready uh I'm dying for
this
okay Josh The Edge you have over here is
sharp enough it lerate to the first
layer but not into the second layer
overall it is sharp enough to puncture
and
lacerate good job thank you Ray are you
ready I'm always
[Music]
ready your Edge over here lacerated to
two layers the outer layer and the first
layer of the Kevlar en forced bag so
it's sharp it will cut
perfect blad Smiths the judges have made
a final decision and it's time for one
of you to leave the
forge Robbie your blade did not make the
cut Robbie this isn't about what your
knife does to the test it's about what
the test does to your knife out of all
three blades your blade had the most
Edge damage and that's why we have to
send you home okay Robbie please
surrender your
weapon you know I have no regrets the
last time I didn't get to finish the
knife I didn't get to see it tested this
time I did I I've
accomplished what I come to
do you know even though I didn't become
to for fire Champion there's a lot of
people behind me
and
[Music]
I can't do this
y'all